okay matthew
hey good morning nice to see you again
yes likewise i like your haircut thank
you
so uh
lots has changed in your life recently
right what's going on now totally well
after the last interview about um a
month after that i
and i mean i was going downhill not like
anything too crazy i was just running
out of money like i just financially was
getting screwed like i didn't know where
i was i was going to pay rent and stuff
like that it was just all catching up to
me it was the perfect storm and i was
just making it happen going day by day
pretty much and then i got an email one
day randomly from uh somebody that
watches the channel and she was a woman
that um lived in colorado or lives in
colorado and she um
doesn't really have any family left i
guess you know people have passed away
she never had kids she never got married
and so she kind of just does her own
thing and she um
she inherited a lot of or from what i
from what i understand she inherited
when her father passed away and she's
done well in her life in the healthcare
field and stuff and
um just had the resources to to help me
and um
she's done this before this you're not
the first person for my channel that
she's right yeah she tried to help
somebody else but they ran off right
yeah they had it handed to them on a
silver platter yeah and she and he just
uh
flanked basically right and i could not
accept it totally yeah and i mean uh
there it took me a couple days to reply
to her because i was like
i mean there's the first part is do i
trust this person do i or is what
they're saying true you know and then
the second part do i deserve it you know
because there's a lot of people that i
feel are way i mean there's tons of
people that are way worse off than me
and it's like well maybe they deserve it
more but
i talked to her and i even said those
things and she said well you know some
of those people like you don't know how
much truth they're telling and um like
how much they want help and i mean i
think i've said it from the start like
that i want to quit like i would love to
get away from this and i mean i'm you
know i've i've been
as honest as i can be you know obviously
i haven't told you that i was working at
trader joe's before but now i can say it
i mean i don't care i left that i just
uh i talked to her and we we set it up
in probably a week and i said i will
drop everything i'll quit my jobs like
i'll leave like i don't i don't care
about anything and i'll go because i was
i was ready and so we set it up and i
came down to socal i um went to a doctor
um
i'm in treatment i'm on suboxone
currently um i got in a sober living
place um and yeah it's it's amazing the
the uh you know the first day i
smoked my last bid at the airport right
before i was gonna get on the plane um
obviously pre-tsa checkpoint um and then
i went and
drank a few beers like got on the plane
had rose the whole way down i mean an
hour flight and i was that was my last
hurrah and so got off the plane
and i get off the plane and these guys
are picking me up all of a sudden i got
a camera in my face and i'm like
what the hell like and so apparently
these guys had some type of idea that
i'm some type of famous because of the
first video getting you know however me
a couple million views or whatever and
so they're asking me all these questions
and it was a little overwhelming but
like i said i was still high and
everything so i was like cool with it
but um went to the doctor and they're
like yeah we're gonna help you out and
then that first night you know i started
coming down and just
was just useless you know just laying
around
and uh
you know it was overwhelming at first
being in a house with about 16 other
guys that are all in different stages of
recovery or coming out of jail or juvie
you know ankle monitors and
all the different stories you know gangs
and stuff it's a very mixed uh bag there
um but the yeah the first night like i'm
trying to sleep and people are just
being loud kids you know young kids 18
19 up all night talking playing video
games and one guy's telling another guy
he should change his name you know his
name's not good enough and oh man i just
wanted to get up and be like shut the
[ __ ] up like oh man but why would i do
that the first day there caused problems
of course not so i just kept to myself
and we went to the doctor the next day
which i didn't want to i wanted to just
lay around but they uh waited until i
was ready for the suboxone they gave me
this actual there's this uh
there's a company called massimo not the
clothing company that's what i thought
it was but it's apparently a healthcare
company um
massimo that has a device called the
bridge device that they hook up to your
ear and it's um supposed to stop
withdrawals in 10 minutes
but it's a blind study it's a
double-blind study so the nurse doesn't
know and i don't know if you're getting
the fake one or the real one
i got the fake one so instead of you
know dealing with the withdrawals i had
to wait another hour and then i'm going
this is not doing anything
they gave me a 50 target gift card so
whatever but um
yeah so that didn't work then they gave
me the suboxone i started feeling a
little bit better just not as much
stomach pain which is the worst part of
the withdrawals and i just slept in that
doctor's office all day and uh the first
day i took 16 milligrams of suboxone two
eight milligram strips the second day i
took it down to twelve and the third day
i took it down to eight because that's
the bare minimum you have to do to
qualify for the i believe it's either
the sublicate or the vivitrol shot
um and so that's what i hope to do
because
uh after a three a few weeks or a month
of taking suboxone you are eligible to
get this shot which
from what i understand you either get
one or two once a month uh
either the first one i people have said
different things i'll believe the doctor
i'll listen to what he says is that i
guess the first shot's 100 milligrams
and the second one is 300 and then you
can just never take anything again and
it'll just slowly trail out of your
system i guess there was one guy that
took it or got the shot and like a year
later he was still testing positive for
it so it was still in his system
and apparently you don't experience any
withdrawals like there might be a day
where you feel a little off or sweaty
but that's the goal because
while i do i love sabbat i mean i love
suboxone not like i loved heroin you
know i'm not getting high off of it but
i love it because i feel normal again
like i'm not waiting for the dealer
every day i'm not spending 100 a day i'm
waking up at a normal time like i yeah i
just it's great and the crazy thing is
this whole time i was using
for eight years i forgot that i'm
naturally energetic i naturally like
have the drive to do things and for the
longest time i was using because i was
like oh i need this to feel good and
feel like i can do things but it was
just i had gone so long by doing that
that i forgot how i normally was so
it's insane
how long has it been that you've been on
it's been almost a month it's like 25
days now that i've been you feel like
you could function normally oh totally i
i just got a job last week
so that's great yeah i uh do like
prepped meals and stuff was helping out
in the kitchen and then just the last
day i was there the manager asked me if
i wanted to be the quality control
manager so you know it's it's great like
obviously i was always able to work and
stuff but it's nice not having to go run
off to the bathroom four to eight times
over an eight hour shift you know and
then if somebody says anything you gotta
lie and say oh i got stomach problems or
something and you know people don't want
to argue with that they believe you but
it's still a lie and you're living a lie
and i mean hiding in the bathroom and
having to blow the smoke into wadded up
toilet paper to absorb the smoke and
different things like that you know i
was always very careful but
um
it's uh it's good to not have to do
those things anymore and to be honest
with people and you know my family and
you know my friends and everything
everybody you know really notices a big
change and i feel bad for
for lying all those years you know but
um
it's a good thing you know that thank
you it's a it's a it's a great thing
that i'm here and i'm so thankful for
the person that helped me out
and i know there's a lot of people that
need help
i feel bad because i don't sometimes i
don't feel like
i mean i feel i feel like it was worth
it and that it was a good idea and that
she'd made the right decision i just
feel guilty because i know there's so
many people that need help
and i've been through so much worse but
being able to accept the help is key
because i i've seen so many people who's
you know their stories break my heart
and i like i can't not help them right
so i'll do everything from from getting
them housing to getting to rehab to
buying them vehicles and all kinds of
crazy stuff totally and i see how they
just
they'll sabotage their own life right
right
and uh i mean regardless of how much
support i'm giving yeah it's just they
just they don't feel they deserve it i
think yeah and so the fact that you can
move forward and do this and feel good
about it and yeah accept it
accepting it's a big one yeah this is
super important for the first i don't
know maybe 10 days or a couple weeks you
know they were like having the manager
of the house there's a guy and his
girlfriend that you know
watch over everything and make sure
everybody follows the rules and
everything
um
he was holding on to all the my money
that i had you know uh well all of it
now like i had a bunch but just to make
sure and so over time you know they
realized they could trust me and stuff
and so now i've been able to have money
and i got a last paycheck from the
lifeguarding job and it was like i owed
a bunch of money from my phone bill that
i had put off and so i got this money
and it was so nice to go okay well i got
this chunk of money i need to pay the
phone bill and that was it instead if i
was using it would be like well i could
probably screw off the phone bill for a
few more days and i could go get high
it's amazing how scandalous uh drug
addicts can be yeah i didn't realize i
didn't you know i'm naive and i didn't
realize how
incredibly scandalous some of these
people can be right the lies that
they'll tell i tried never to get that
deep but i definitely there were times
like at work where
i would come up with a reason like i had
to leave or something you know stuff
like that or like tell people i was
going somewhere else but it was never
like hey i'm gonna watch your house and
they come back the next day and all
their shit's gone you know it's never
anything like that uh i just feel too
guilty but um the the money thing you
know i've i've had money in my pocket
and apparently where i'm staying it's
not the best neighborhood it's not the
worst either but i could go around the
corner to the liquor store and there are
guys posted up apparently this like main
street like you can get whatever all day
and i haven't even thought about it i
haven't even thought once like oh if i
asked this guy or maybe i could just do
a little bit and like one crazy thing is
um we went to some event the other night
that's the other thing about getting
sober is you know there's the whole 12
steps in recovery community aana
religion christianity all that [ __ ] and
i am agnostic i believe that there's
something out there but who am i to tell
you what it is i'm
i mean people can't remember what they
did last week half the time so how could
you tell me that for sure something that
happened thousands of years ago and then
if you're telling me that's a fact what
are you going to tell buddhists or
muslims that what they're what they
believe in is wrong so that's my view is
that there's something but who am i
gonna you know i can't tell you so um
there's been a lot of uh people like in
the recovery community that want to tell
me what i need to do and what's going to
work for me and the if i don't i'm going
to relapse in however many months which
is great i guess you know they're
they're trying to care or whatever but i
think that's also that could be
counterproductive i feel like there's a
lot of people that get scared off i've i
mean i've seen people go to aanna
meetings and go use right after because
they're so annoyed like or i mean
there's been people in a n a that go
kill themselves like a few months down
the road and they're clean and sober but
everybody's different everybody's unique
so i don't think to shove something down
a new person's throat especially is a
great idea that's how some people are
and that's great i mean they don't have
to talk to me anymore and i have to talk
to them so
um
but i went to this event the other night
and it was like we got wrangled into it
oh yeah it's gonna be like a party
there's food you know sober party and
and all this stuff which there was
but what it was is we're gonna go
introduce you to these guys that have
their little sober group and they're
going to preach to you and tell you
their story and then try to get you to
come to their events
so we went to this uh event a little
party at somebody's house it's like a
recovery house and
they had you know live music and food
and everything um
but the one guy that i met there he was
the brother of the the house manager's
girlfriend
and uh you know he's just a cool guy
he's like a month sober and metame
seemed great and then a couple nights
later there was like a sublime tribute
show which you know i'm not a big
sublime fan anything but it was
something to do i mean we're getting
kind of bored and so he went and he
saved the seats for us and we went and
we all you know just watched the show
had a good time eight or whatever and
went home
and then a couple nights later or a
couple days later in the morning we get
up and we found out that that guy oda
fentanyl and he died and so
it was like
i've actually through eight years of
using i've never known anybody that's
died
and so
it was like holy [ __ ] like i was just
with this guy the other night and i even
remember at one point he was like on his
phone like by himself and like i had the
thought to like go up to him and talk to
him because i know like how it feels to
be like alone and just be on your phone
and i mean not that i like think oh i
could have saved this guy's life or
anything i mean shit's gonna happen if
it's gonna happen but you never know
what little interaction could change the
course of somebody's life so
you know i mean anybody could have done
anything at any point but that's just
the way it works out so now they're like
dealing with this funeral all that [ __ ]
and so it's like this is like [ __ ]
scared straight for me you know like
where they send the kids into the jail
and the guys are like yelling at him
like
we got we had like a bed bug scared dude
like i
this freaking thing was from me
scratching it like i never had sores and
stuff when i was using now i feel like i
look like a [ __ ] crackhead no not
that sorry that's a that's like using it
as an insult that's not nice but um
yeah just the bad book thing and then i
i flipped out over that i like went to
the doctor and got an argument with him
you know when your doctor needs to take
a smoke break because he's the [ __ ] you
just laid on him like wow that must be
he he was like i haven't in like three
years needed to take a break away from
somebody but you were really get because
we were arguing over something i was
trying to call him to tell him about the
bed bugs i felt like he was ignoring me
and then
iphones the way they work with delivery
and read receipts and turning your phone
off kind of you know
it doesn't do that i was trying to
explain that to him because it seemed
like he turned his phone off on me
and he took it personally but we got
over it and we uh made amends and then
he put us up in a hotel room and bought
us pizza while they sprayed the house
and so the bed bugs are gone but
it's been a it's been eye-opening it's
it's definitely i'm out of my element
and it's where i needed to go it's it's
good that i mean there were a couple
days where i was upset and depressed but
when it's all said and done i'm like
this is real life and this is reality
and it's what i need to experience like
it's good to feel comfortable in
recovery but it's also good to feel
uncomfortable because you need to
remember that like you put yourself here
and and these are i mean it's there's
always going to be lingering
consequences
um
but for the most part i mean
everything's great and i feel great i
have tons of energy happy
talking to family every day keeping in
contact with people you know
building relationships again trying you
know meeting new people and and also the
house being very um eclectic of the
personalities there's a lot of younger
kids um kids that are 18 19 years old
they were doing fentanyl and uh i mean
it's just it's crazy because i mean
luckily they're getting clean or
you know i don't know who's
you know who let's hear things you don't
know who's lying or who's but these kids
are getting tested by the courts so i i
really would hope they're staying clean
so they don't go back to jail
but um yeah there's there's gang members
there's you know people fresh out of
jail and everybody's really respectful
to each other and cool for the most part
keep the house clean and everything it's
a struggle isn't it
yeah but it's it's a good struggle now
at this point the i got through the bad
struggle tell me about suboxone
suboxone so your cravings are gone
yeah but other people still apparently
have them i'm just uh they also say
probably because i was smoking and i
wasn't injecting like that that's a big
deal and it's a lot easier for me but um
i just take eight milligram strip a day
i put it under my tongue and and i don't
feel any different really i mean there
was a time where i accidentally like
went 30 hours without it you're supposed
to take it every 24 and i didn't start
feeling anything it has a longer i guess
i don't know if it's half life if that's
a term but
it takes you longer to start feeling
like crap but i've heard it's also worse
withdrawals if you stop it completely so
um that's why i would like to get off of
it because i mean i know somebody that's
only taking one milligram a day so i
mean
you can go very low but it's just
i wouldn't mind being on it but it's
just the mental thing of being feeling
like you're addicted to something you
know so that's why that shot seems like
a good idea yeah i've said this before
but
it still kind of
hits home every time with me the ability
the belief that you deserve a better
life
is key
totally and so many of these people that
you see on my channel
they don't believe they deserve a better
life than than what you're seeing right
and they even if they were given
everything on a silver platter
everything they need housing job
education
you know therapy everything yeah they
wouldn't know what to do with it right
and in doing this now i've thought like
whereas you seem to be able to move
forward and yeah yeah take this ball and
run with it right which i'm sure there's
tons of people watching that are gonna
watch this and be like this dude is
gonna [ __ ] up in a month or something
which is great great go ahead think that
every single video i'll prove them wrong
and if if somehow which i'm not i'm not
so naive that i'm like it's 100
like if there's that little chance that
something bad happens then damn man i
hope i really hope that i i i
that's not even in my mind
you're not sitting here telling us that
you are cured and everything's fine no
because i it recovery is a continuing
process you never get over it you don't
graduate it's for the rest of your life
yeah that's right it's a struggle yeah
and so uh
it's you know i've been content just
working these random jobs like trader
joe's lifeguard warehouse jobs delivery
jobs sales jobs just here and there and
uh now that i've like been you know here
and getting sober and stuff i'm like
well i would really like to do something
to help people you know in recovery
after i get you know through with this
and even if uh that's you know something
that i find out that i don't really want
to do if i get into it
uh i've just i don't know what it is
something has inspired me like i was
watching something on the news uh which
i never watched the news it was just on
and it was a called coast to coast uh
something about going over the border
wall and these two reporters drove from
florida to california and they went on
both sides of the border and interviewed
people
and i just like never realized like
how
how bad like people have it in certain
parts of mexico and like it's just not
doesn't seem very fair to like
keep them out i mean i understand both
sides but man some people are like just
facing death and extortion and stuff
which i you know i kind of knew about
cartels and everything but
it's just some people struggle so hard
and then they go through this long
journey risking their lives to get here
just to have a better life for them and
their children or you know
and so
i don't know i'd i'd love to get into
some type of immigration law type field
or something i don't know 35 years old
so
you're saying
we'll see i mean there's tons of
opportunities now and like life's you
know open playing field you know because
i have the
heroine out of my system and that was
just bringing me down and suppressing me
which like i said i thought it was
making me better you seem much more
positive and your energy even you say
you're like well if it makes you better
then everybody was like oh why'd he say
that
what did i say
in the first interview you were like
whoa i mean if it makes you feel better
like then maybe you're like i'm not
promoting heroin but you because i i was
so
i don't know if it was like i was so
high or just such a good mood or i
wanted to seem like that to the world
you know i wasn't like yeah i bought it
back i read through that but but i don't
i try not to judge in these interviews
and i also try to be devil's eye for you
right like if a pimp is telling me that
oh whatever i'm gonna be like yeah that
sounds great yes that's just to kind of
like let him do his thing and that's
like even you've said like ignore the
mean comments like ignore the bad stuff
i like to play devil's advocate to
myself so i like to absorb like they say
keep your enemies closer than your
friends like even though they're saying
something negative except that people
are like [ __ ] him he's a douchebag i
don't think about that twice but people
that have like some type of valid point
like i understand they're a person too
with their own viewpoints and their own
unique opinion and so i would be stupid
not to think of that and at least think
why do they feel this way about me you
know like is it's not even oh can i
change to appease them it's like maybe i
have flaws or maybe there's other ways
of thinking and so there's actually been
a couple of times that i've responded to
people like that and we talk and then at
the end they're like you know what like
i'm sorry i said that and i'm like it's
cool i understand and then like yeah
sometimes sometimes sometimes they just
want to be acknowledged yeah engage in
the conversation and i've seen people
turn around as well but that's cool yeah
i find it just depresses me if i get
engaged in comments and other people
yeah they just won't stop they're just
so hard-headed and it's fine yeah yeah
well i'm happy for you i'm glad you met
this uh
this anonymous angel that's right on my
channel i know her very well yes
thank you so much for you know giving me
the opportunity and thank you to her for
helping me out but um yeah it's it's
great man and
i hope uh keep going on the right path i
hope you take this ball and run with it
for sure you deserve thank you so much i
appreciate it thank you